so starting on monday a trip to the dmv
a little different than usual there is a
new process to help cut cut down on
those wait times yeah so now you must go
online not physically in line to take
care of business jeremy j ford was at
the dmv on sahara near eastern with what
drivers are saying about those changes
[Music]
by appointment only is the new process
the dmv will be following starting
monday but the folks that i spoke to
that were walk-ins today tell me they
feel it won't speed things up
frustrating
because this is the second day i
am trying to get some things done here
at the dmv alicia flamini thought just
walking in and getting in line at the
dmv would help her take care of the
services she needs but instead she was
told they're full
and i have to try back tomorrow to fix
the problem of long wait lines and
turning people away the dmv is moving to
an appointment only process but even
with an appointment croatia foster
doesn't think it's faster services i'm
here i was here on time 15 minutes early
but now i'm having to wait
you know i'm 39th in line so i'm
frustrated because one i have to pick up
my daughter we have to go do school
supplies i have work so i'm a little
aggravated right now the online changes
are due to staffing shortages and an
influx of walk-ins the dmv will be
adding more than 4 000 appointments per
week to southern nevada locations we
need your help do your transaction
online if at all possible jeremy j ford
live local now